do people really understand the Scale of
the Universe damn really that's okay
this task is going to seem ridiculously
easy rank these uh things from smallest
at the top to biggest on the bottom but
sometimes you have to ask the question
no one would bother to in order to
figure out what people are actually
thinking this is really going to put my
astronomy skills to the test so I don't
know Moon yeah I'd say moon is probably
small I say stars are smallest but the
sun is a star this like science place
going say planets are the smallest I say
Planet might be the top of the line is
the Sun bigger than the moon what
depends on the planet right it does but
is a general category Stars bin moons
and then there stars y around the planet
the sun is a star right I think it is
you think this one's next I trust you
cuz we're talking about a Galaxy bro
we're talking everything you looking at
the Galaxy
too here like
okay I think it's this one and then this
one you're right you can wait no unless
you believe in the Multiverse then you
know you're taking this like
four-dimensional chest level I think the
moon would be bigger no I mean you think
right cuz like it it looks bigger yeah
is this supposed to be like a science
lesson like there is there's definitely
some science to this okay we are not
astrology
[Laughter]
Majors so what is a moon like how's a
moon different from a planet um the
ction of dust maybe the way that they
come about in astrology and like the I
don't know like the meteors planets is
like human life already exist or
potentially can exist and a planet has
its own like I don't know I feel a
planet is capable of having its own
atmosphere or something and then the
atmosphere of the moon and the planet
are completely different whether or not
it has like an atmosphere I get why some
people would think this because the
Earth has an atmosphere while our moon
has essentially no atmosphere but Titan
Saturn's largest moon actually has a
thick atmosphere while mercury has no
substantial atmosphere so if having an
atmosphere isn't what makes a planet
then what is it you don't know if the
moon has people on it it could um you
think the moon could have people on it
there could be Moon people we never know
I'm thinking like orbits or something
something around there I think I think
natural satellite is the term used so so
they you you'll always have moons around
a planet you can't see a planet around a
moon how many planets do we know
of
uh I don't know I guess let's see a
seven eight seven or nine do we have 11
in our soul system I think a planet has
to be certain size to be considered a
planet cuz if you look at Pluto they say
it's not a planet it's too small Pluto
doesn't count as a planet anymore
Pluto's technically not a planet
everyone knows the poor story of of
Pluto because everybody loves
Pluto when Pluto was discovered in 1930
it was hailed the ninth planet but it
quickly became clear that Pluto was
different the real nail in the coffin
came on the 5th of January 2005 when
astronomers discovered ays an object in
the Kyper belt that's around 30% more
massive than Pluto similar large objects
had already been discovered and more
were likely to follow so scientists
faced a choice either add a whole bunch
more planets or demote Pluto in 2006 the
decision was made and a new definition
for a planet was established they should
just like get over it Pluto had it
coming from the beginning stay in your
lane stay in your lanean our moon has
five times the mass of Pluto so just
just get over it was our moon a planet
no it's a moon to be a planet an object
now had to satisfy three criteria first
it must orbit the sun second it must
have enough self-gravity so that it's
round or almost round and third it must
be gravitationally dominant and cleared
out its neighborhood Pluto sat satisfies
the first two criteria but not the third
so now we're back to the set of planets
without
Pluto Mercury Venus Earth Mars Jupiter
Saturn Uranus Neptune oh it's eight nice
and he named them all bonus points how
many planets outside the solar system
oh maybe around couple hundred to a
thousand maybe probably couple million
probably more than that probably
I mean in terms of the number that we
know is about 5,000 right now that have
been identified but like there you're
right there's many more but we just
haven't haven't seen them yet so we
don't know so the moons are the smallest
they go around the planets planets go
around the Stars what makes a star a
star kind of like a dead planet right
like like it's just emitting heat like
little gas things and they explode all
the time and we don't even see them but
I don't know where they come from can
you tell me if you have a bunch of just
like gas as you say like hydrogen helium
that all kind of clumps together it
forms a star and then like you say
there's like Fusion in the middle
explosions in the middle that are giving
out light and heat and stuff like that
wow you just taught me something new I
didn't even know that there you go
doesn't it take eight Earths to fill the
Sun a millionaires a millionaires I got
it wrong okay I'm stupid no no but like
it's a lot right here's one way to put
this in perspective in our solar system
there are eight planets hundreds of
moons millions of asteroids and more but
in terms of mass all that only makes up
.4% of the mass of our solar system the
other
99.86% of the mass is the Sun that is
just how much bigger and more massive
the sun is Moon smallest and
planets and
stars well what is a Galaxy like what is
that uh a group of planets in in I'd say
a certain amount of proximity like the
solar system like the system of planets
so like just how we have our solar
system is what makes the Galaxy ton of
stars moons and planets and together
makes the
Galaxy just a collection of like solar
systems so how many is a collection of
solar systems how how big is a Galaxy
how many
stars
uh wa I don't know a friend 60,000
Millions I'd say Millions tens of
millions of stars perhaps how many stars
in a
galaxy roughly fall
part probably hundreds of millions
million
billion 100 billion oh you are way off
crazy oh my God crazy you said 6 100
billion 100 billion damn really that's
okay number of stars in a galaxy that
can vary depending on the size of the
Galaxy but like 100 billion 200 billion
300 billion 50 billion like that's like
kind of fall Park num the average is 100
billion yeah that's crazy right yeah
they're huge there's a funny question
are there more trees on Earth or stars
in our
galaxy
if oh actually I'm now thinking about
like a math problem where it's basically
you have to find I guess the whole
entire surface area of that
ooh the answer is I'll save you the
trouble there are more trees on Earth
than there are stars in the in the
galaxy in our Milky Way galaxy you know
what figures you
know so a galaxy is a huge collection of
stars planets gas dust dark matter and
other objects all bound together by
gravity and then what what is around the
Milky Way galaxy um more galaxies there
are more galaxies but they're kind of
far away so what's between us and those
other galaxies yeah uh uh like all types
of vastness you know supernovas Dark
Matter
Stars you know this is the thing that I
find nuts and one of the things I wanted
to see if people know but like the Milky
Way is like one Galaxy but it's huge
it's like 100,000 light years across
that's pretty big you know what I mean
but then around us there's nothing oh
wow I didn't basically nothing yeah it's
kind of like the continents right you
have a continent but then around it like
there's all this ocean MH and then
there's like more
galaxies and then there's nothing and
then more galaxies and nothing more
galaxies nothing but this animation is
not to scale really it should look more
like this the distances between galaxies
are enormous typically millions of light
years if you zoom out further you find
that galaxies are grouped together in
clusters and those clusters make up even
larger superclusters all separated by
enormous voids and you know how many
galaxies there are in the universe uh
I'll take a guess and say like 20
something uh how many galaxies in the
universe if I
know 12 I don't know is it is that like
close it's more much more oh much more
I'm going to say 100 more than hundreds
thousands more than thousands oh my gosh
10,000
10,000 10,000 that that's small uh I
mean 10,000 Galaxy but each Galaxy's got
100 billion stars
16,48 hundreds of thousands
millions billions 1 billion or is that
is that too small 1 billion galaxies
each one with 100 billion stars I'll say
10 billion that we know of what are you
going to say the answer is the answer is
how many galaxies in the universe
about Dar it 100
billion what really about 100 billion
galaxies holy seriously yeah about 100
billion dang weird oh man is huge 100
billion are observable and those are
these are just galaxies these are
galaxies each Galaxy then has about 100
billion stars okay right that's mind
blowing a little bit right yeah this is
what I'm saying I feel like most people
don't know this Scale of the Universe
and that's what I'm out here to talk
about that's why I wanted to be like
it's so much bigger than almost anyone
thinks right in fact there could be even
more because 100 billion galaxies is a
conservative estimate some believe there
are up to 2 trillion galaxies in the
observable
universe so it's huge and between all
these galaxies nothing
nothing what a wacky Universe right yeah
and around each star there might be on
average about six
planets wow so you can think about 100
billion time 100 billion time 6 roughly
and that's conservative Okay and like
number of planets maybe in the universe
mhm so it's insanely huge yes that do
sound in that is actually wow I feel
like it makes me less stressed because
it's just a blip in the system man
nothing's ever that deep so the universe
is insanely huge and we're incredibly
small I got you how does that make you
feel think about the size of it very
small I don't know it doesn't make me
feel that small there's not you still
feel pretty big I don't feel big but you
know I still feel like this Earth in
particular has a a pretty decent amount
of signific whatever you know
significance this is a special place for
sure yeah on the 14th of February 1990
the Voyager 1 spacecraft was about 6
billion kilm from the sun when it took
this
picture all you see are a few Ray of
light and a little
dot Carl Sean described this picture
best look again at that dot that's here
that's home that's us on it everyone you
love everyone you know everyone you ever
heard of every human being whoever was
lived out their lives every hero and
coward every Creator and destroyer of
civilization every young couple in love
every mother and father inventor and
Explorer every superstar every supreme
leader every saint and sinner in the
history of our species lived there on a
moat of dust suspended in a
Sunbeam the Earth is a very small stage
in a vast Cosmic Arena to me it
underscores our responsibility to deal
more kindly with one another and to
preserve and cherish the pale blue dot
the only home we've ever known
I'm glad you taught me something today I
appreciate it I like learning that's
awesome well thank you for um being open
to learning cuz that's so important the
thing that people are worried about is
making mistakes but you can't learn
without making mistakes a lot of
[Music]
times so many people don't know the
basics about the universe we live in but
it can even be hard to understand the
world we live in and this has a lot to
do with our media ecosystem which often
prioritizes speed over accuracy
and sensationalism over facts a problem
that's so big in science communication I
made a whole video about it but ground
news the sponsor of this video changes
the game by giving you the tools to
consume news in a more nuanced and
transparent way was founded by a former
NASA engineer and it gathers articles
from around the world in one spot so
ground news shows how different Outlets
cover the same story and gives you
context about the source of the
information take a look at this study on
on America's trust in science I can see
that more than 10 articles were
published on it and if I scroll down I
can read them all in one place next to
each headline there are tags showing me
who owns the outlet how reliable their
reporting is and if they have a
political bias what's interesting is
that some headlines just mention a
decline in trust some link it to covid
and others focus on the trend being
worse in minorities ground news also
gives a biased distribution chart
showing me that this story is mostly
covered by Center leaning sources with
little coverage from the left and none
from the right so for readers living in
a right leaning media bubble this would
be a blind spot ground news actually
sorts stories like this into a separate
feed so you can see what topics both
sides of the political Spectrum tend to
focus on and make sure you're getting
the full picture go to ground. news/
veritasium to check it out or click the
link in the description and if you sign
up using our link you'll get 30% off
their unlimited access plan a
subscription helps support ground news
to make the media landscape more
transparent so I would like to thank
ground news for sponsoring this video
and I'd like to thank you for watching